[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and today on our ask an expert
segment we have
pro fighter ron with us he's my coach
and well technically you're not my coach
anymore right no
because you haven't coached me like six
months did i just get fired you're fired
no it's just you know the quarantine and
corona stuff it's just hard to meet up
and train
but yeah ron coached me for maybe like
two years
and i thought it'd be cool to have ron
come on as our pro fighter guest
yeah i was a part-time athlete for ron
for six months or so that was pretty fun
dude that was really fun training with
you guys at like
six in the morning in front of your
front lawn on the driveway yeah dude the
neighbors were all walking their dogs
and stuff and
we were out there kicking our lives away
yeah remember when
i was having you guys do a conditioning
part of it too and then slowly
we would take the conditioning away yeah
that was so
hard man because it's like we're already
tired mentally drained and then we start
the class
after it was like a crazy circuit or
whatever
i don't know that those days were crazy
yeah i always got the invite uh
thanks for letting me know about it
pretty good though
thank you so i have a question um
let's say just from like scratch right i
don't know any martial arts nothing
and i watch ufc and i'm like man i want
to be a pro fighter
what are the steps from beginning that i
need to take
for sure so you got to decide what
avenue you want to go if you want to go
to
do the ufc type of stuff that's mma that
means you need a strike
and grapple if you want to do just
striking then generally it's like boxing
or something like that or if you want to
just grapple then you go to like jiu
jitsu or wrestling or judo
what if it's ufc i see all that [ __ ] on
tv
and i want to be like them bam yeah so
if you want to do full
mma you need to learn how to strike you
need to learn how to grapple um there's
two avenues you can go
you can piece it out and you can find a
grappling art and you can find a
striking yard at two different gyms or
dojos
or you can find a gym that kind of
covers it all in mma gym because ufc is
mma mixed martial arts
you're mixing martial arts together and
so to
properly do mixed martial arts you need
to learn how to strike and grapple and
then how to transition between the two
and so the popular recipe right now is
boxing or muay thai and wrestling and
jiu jitsu and so generally and you
the cool part of the ufc is or ufc ufc
is cool but um and mma in general is you
could do anything you do taekwondo you
do kung fu
like you can do karate um but are those
less effective
it's not that it's less effective it's
just less popular do those guys like all
hate each other
like internally it's like uh karate guys
like they they the
jujitsu guys and like it's like the navy
and the army and all that [ __ ]
um it's like that's a maybe way back in
the day like like ufc one days like old
school days it would be like literally
street brawler versus like karate guy
that was the best dude i remember the
game street fighter
yeah yeah that was like ufc man
you know a much difference in character
now it's like kind of one thing
yeah now it's all more sporty-ish let's
fight you know originally the eoc was
designed uh one of their plans was to
have an alligator pit
around the cage that's sick yeah like
originally in there
the original fall and an alligator could
bite your ass yeah because
they wanted to make it a spectacle you
know yeah but obviously you know with
lawyers and everything's like that's by
not a guy yeah of course the lawyers got
involved freaking lawyers
because back in the day like you would
have like you know
um like the gracie like dude like hoist
in a ghee or like you you'd have a
wrestling guy in a wrestling outfit or
like
it's just different there's even a boxer
that's only wearing one glove yeah
because he he wanted one i think to at
least like protect his knuckles
and then i think the other one he wanted
he i think he was seeing like royce
gracie do his things he goes i need one
hand to at least like protect from the
grappler
so in the best of both worlds grapple
hand punching it's all experimental back
there
crazy innovative yeah i love it uh but
yeah to get in there i would find
two separate schools um google is your
best friend right or siri whatever
find me the nearest mma gym and then um
she'll be like yeah arco is four miles
away
but not all of them are the same right
like don't you gotta choose one that's
good or like
hopefully choose one that has already
produced fighters that
gone to the ufc yeah i mean just like
anything else you're trying to get into
uh do your research you know you want to
whatever it is you're trying to do make
sure it's a good quality has a good
reputation and whatnot
um but regardless if sometimes you might
be like in the middle of nowhere in
wichita kansas or something and
maybe there's only one gym available so
it's either you train at the one gym you
don't train at all
or you move to like la or somewhere yeah
you know so resources may be limited so
i would say
regardless of where you're in the world
make the best of it if you only have one
source available and it's only taekwondo
jump into taekwondo you know maybe help
push the culture to implement more
martial arts into it
but i would say find a striking art find
a grappling art and then once you get
the fundamentals of that
then you have to find uh an instructor
that'll teach you how to
implement the two because they mix them
together mix them together which is a
whole nother martial art
so if you think learning would tie by
itself is hard or jujitsu by itself is
hard
it's a whole other thing to learn how to
put them together which ones do you do
i do muay thai boxing uh jiu jitsu and
wrestling
all right i mean i do that all in house
wrestling like wwe [ __ ] that's sick dude
yeah um yeah right and that's what makes
it so confusing when you say wrestling
you think like i'm gonna jump off a
turnbuckle
no i think you're talking [ __ ] into a
microphone
i'm calling you out man i love that [ __ ]
and you spray water
and they do that now i mean you see you
see that now there's a lot of theatrics
in
in current mma which i think kind of
makes it a little more entertaining and
fun
you know like you see conor mcgregor
fighting soon like it's been cool to see
today
yeah today oh yeah it's funny today
tonight yeah but even how he promotes
a little bit different now he's more
like mature and like they're
co-promoting each other like he's he's
promoting uh dustin's hot sauce
you know stuff like that whereas before
he'd be like f your hot sauce
f your country f your team you know i'm
gonna embarrass all of you
and so like on one end it's cool to see
how mature he's gotten but number two
it's also like
it's kind of more fun to see like a
little more wild in here i missed the
promos where guys were just behind that
um the chain-link fence with sprinklers
on them
yes they'll spray they'll miss you with
water and just
punch into the camera oh yeah she's the
best
the bj pen days yeah yeah
and just turn with the head yep for like
um
people that need that wanna get into the
ufc what is like
a full fighters like schedule look like
i mean just like anything else if you
want to be the best of something you got
to do it full time is it a nine of five
times
um what would like a typical day look
like a typical day when you're fighting
full time
is for just team training generally
there's two team training sessions a day
um so like for me it's 11 a.m until 2
p.m and then three hours
yeah what do you do with that no three
hours just punch each other for three
hours
it's a it's a little bit of everything
and those are just training specifics so
we'll
we'll drill we'll cover technique we'll
even watch tape sometimes
um and then we'll it'll happen when the
teacher rolls in the the tv with the vcr
i always like that i'm like yes we're
gonna do a little bit less work today
well what's up is when he rolls in the t
that means practice is just gonna last
longer so we'll do the same amount of
stuff
i'm like dang it so sometimes class will
go until like three um and then we gotta
come back at six
and then train until nine um and then we
do a
few other types so far this sounds like
[ __ ]
why would i wanna do this it makes you
happy
yeah yeah i mean you're chasing the
dream like it's just like those little
kids that say like i want to be
yes or no we're not growing up you know
and then now you're seeing little kids
that literally say
i want to be a ufc fighter when i grow
up it's like a freaking thing you know
yeah the kids are training now at like
five years old
what it's crazy yeah they're starting
jiu jitsu and wrestling already like
they already have better technique than
most of us
um they're starting young yo i see kids
that are like
three snowboarding and skiing man like
they're smaller than taika and i'm like
wow this is why the next generation is
going to come up with some
crazier stuff yeah it's nice yeah like
when i was five i was picking my nose
like literally that was the highlight of
my day yeah like check it out
you know this is cool that's a huge
boost you've got fresh boogers and
you're like yeah
yeah it tastes good too you know i had
to give it up
between those two team sessions what
else because i see on your instagram
like you're like running and then
lifting weights and you gotta do all
these other
when do you fit in the other stuff yeah
so you got to fit in between that's
where it's kind of like up to the
individual right and so
if you're doing the maximum like
everything you can like my teammates
that are like killing her now like
cheeto vera alex
alex perez carla sparza you know they
are
full on they're training full-time you
know
they're doing strength conditioning they
are running they are swimming they are
cycling they're stretching
they're resting they're recuperating
they're doing physical therapy um
like literally this whole thing takes a
whole day i mean therapy alone takes
like two hours they're sitting there and
they'll put some like gizmos on you and
your muscles will twitch
and they'll wrap you in ice they'll like
strap a chain to your head and like
stretch your neck
uh to like lengthen your spine um all
kinds of fun stuff
wow but um it's it's it's literally a
whole day
and rest is important too you know a lot
of people really um
really downplay how important rest is it
you know our culture is like if you rest
you're lazy
you know whereas like it's quite the
opposite you know if you rest
enough it actually makes you more
productive you know and so
let's say a regular schedule 6 a.m i'll
be running um i need to rest eat you
know
and then 11 a.m i train 2 p.m i'm out
strength conditioning from like two to
four
eat rest a little bit more and then 6 30
you're back on the grind with the team
and then train again and then at night
you kind of just kind of relax with us
now you eat
you rest and then the morning you do it
all again when you say rest you mean
like
taking a nap like you take three naps a
day um kind of just like kind of chill
like
like don't work out anymore just watch
stuff yeah because you don't want to be
spent out for like night training
um how do you make time for netflix
hulu nothing absolutely nothing maybe
fight tape
wow so let's say the training part you
know we went over that
now when you're ready to like start
competing how do you
get into like what are the leagues or
levels you
you do before you get into the ufc yeah
he's starting like a garage backyard
shoot you can i mean some of these guys
in the ufc do stuff from the garage
like kimbo yeah chemo slice dude oh my
gosh i made massive doll too
fudge yeah you started from the street
now he's freaking one of the biggest
stars
you either go viral and famous or
whatever
or kind of like how the paul brothers
got into boxing
yeah like that or if you don't do that
and you don't you're not like an
instagram sensation or whatever
if you're going the traditional route
what does that look like
what are the like what's the amateur
level and then you become pro and all
that
it's a it's a really long route and it's
not even it's not even
cookie cutter black and white you do
these things you will get there um
it's you do these things and you'll
increase your chances of getting in
because it's one you have to be
[Music]
qualified you have to have the right
resume but number two they have to want
you
like literally ufc has the power to be
like you fit everything you're
undefeated you're 50 and oh nobody has
beat you
but we don't want you uh maybe because
maybe your personality's not there or
maybe we just don't like you
and we don't think you're a good fit for
our company and they can do that holy
[ __ ] so
you spend your whole lives you spend
your whole life chasing this dream
and it's not guaranteed but that's
everything in life you know is that what
happened to colby covington where he was
like killing it
and on paper he was like a really good
fighter um but they were just they were
gonna cut him just because he didn't
bring in like a crowd and so he adopted
the whole like manga thing started
wearing like cheap suits and then also
it started being a [ __ ] talker
as a star yeah so all the people that
are like wait this isn't even the real
kobe coming he put on an act but all of
a sudden now he's
like a big star yeah you know i mean
part of especially fighting for whatever
reason fighting entertainment
plays a huge role the the biggest stars
the highest paydays
have been from people that have made a
ton of splash on news
conor mcgregor's ronda rouseys jon jones
like jon jones is like the biggest name
in mma
and he puts out the most news uh
especially
unrelated fight news right and so like
cocaine and like duis and stuff mm-hmm
yeah you know rampage jackson you know
running in the middle of the
intersection like crashing his car in
the middle of the street
and running around like that's the type
of stuff that that people just
that people want to see i personally
love it yeah people want to see it's a
it's a tv show you know and so um
it plays a huge role so you got to fight
you got to find a team
you can go solo but it's so much harder
you need to find a manager a sports
manager sports agent
to get ufc i mean at that level it's so
hard not to get in without a proper
sports agent
like it's the same thing as getting the
nfl without a support sports agent how
the heck you're going to get in there
so you need their contacts you need
their resources you need their guidance
you fight at the local level turn
amateur you know uh fight enough where
until your coach decides or your
management team decides you're ready
then you fight at a local level at a pro
level and then you
fight there and then pretty much you
make your pitch to the ufc they have
matchmakers
um that make the matches so you actually
have to get in contact with them
you don't actually talk to dana white at
all you talk to matchmakers right now
and sean shelby and another gentleman
your agent would do the talking for you
yeah generally what's a matchmaker
um so they're they're these uh these
guys like tender
yeah exactly they're the tinder they're
ufc tinder guys or tinder persons
would be like this guy fighting this guy
that'll make a good fight
fireworks it's actually a really good
analogy because literally the line of
fighters trying to get the fc
are lined and so they'll come in right
right left
left left right left left and they'll
just start swiping away
um but even so there's a lot of fighters
there's a lot
even right now like for me and my
management company at radium sports
agency
they have for me there's 36 people
um in my weight class in that sports
agency
wow so they represent you and 35 others
and all your competitors
yeah um and that's just one sports
agency and so for me
to get that last minute call so just
have some context to get that last
minute call for me to get the call from
the oc
um i am eighth in line so they're gonna
call seven people
before me for that last minute call to
get in the ufc before i get the call
so those seven people have to say no for
me to get
the the question like you're [ __ ]
horrible odds horrible odds but i still
have a chance
i like it so keep chasing them that's
like football players right
you only get x amount of every year and
then there's
so many people that want to play
football and that are qualified but they
can't get in
yeah that's just that's the reality of
chasing something that a lot of a lot of
people can do the odds are
horrible you know i mean look at how
many people are trying to be
influencers and you know get paid
through youtube and stuff like that it
is few and far in between it is
hard to get there they should quit
i think professional sports
is probably harder to do than um
social media because social media you
might it's like to be the top guys yeah
it's [ __ ] hard right but to make a
living
with decent pay it's much easier than a
professional
ass athlete i think all you need is a
camera and you're already doing it
whereas like with you you gotta wait to
be matched up with somebody and like
fight
and then their payout system is is like
even at the top
it's not as much so that's what that's
yeah
yeah i mean even then like i've been
doing for 17 years and like i do
pretty okay but it's not all from
fighting i had to do a billion different
things to get by
and so stereotypically fighters will
spend their whole life fighting and when
fighting's over they're kind of
they're kind of screwed they're stuck
and stereotypically fighters aren't
great at saving money
uh and so when the careers are over it's
kind of like oh
snap now what do i do you know a lot of
athletes though you know
athletes in general you know like people
think like
five million dollars from mba is a lot
and then they're still going bankrupt
you know because money money can be
spent
all kinds of crazy ways so like for me
for me to get by and sustain lifestyle i
want i have to
i was lucky to get a job to manage a gym
and then teach personal training
and then have a bunch of other
miscellaneous like endeavors and you're
good at saving money
i hope yes yes actually you're good good
good good i actually do
fighters are bad at it i was hoping okay
yeah i don't i do spend irresponsibly
but i do save at the same time
i like i like stuff but i also realize
the importance of saving one what do
fighters usually
blow all their money on eating out um
band-aids for all the cuts yeah it's a
lot of band-aids yeah um even they
expect like the not even the generic
like the name brand kinds more expensive
um yeah just buying stuff i mean shoot
we'll buy we'll buy all kinds of dumb
stuff
um because they train so hard they
probably feel like they gotta like
reward themselves
yeah it's extreme we get pushed we get
pushed to mental and physical extremes
and so it's it's not uncommon to uh even
marijuana we you know like a lot of
fighters buy a ton of weed
to relax like a lot like a whole lot
like i don't smoke
myself but like i'm around so much of it
i'm like man like
how would you guys smoke we should like
set up a store you can monetize this i'm
like
don't smoke it and just sell it yeah
does ufc
do drug testing yes but they just they
just
essentially legalized marijuana oh cool
like like literally like like i think a
week ago
before they would they would suspend you
if you had thc in your system like a
week before the fight
um but now you can have as much as you
want
so it's completely free so that's why um
the diaz brothers may be fighting pretty
soon
your guys's gym has like an interesting
model though right like where
if you're a pro fighter for the team
there's actually like a fighter's house
that
they get to stay at yes um um there's
not many gyms i think
like actually have that kind of like
perk no yeah that one's kind of like a
it's a low-key thing but for whatever
reason people just tend to find out
um a few a few marquee gyms in the u.s
do it and so they'll house fighters so
it's we're scouting we're scouting
across the world for people that
may be a good prospect that may become a
ufc champion
and so we'll find them through various
sources and then we'll we'll pitch it to
them
um but now it's at a point where people
come into us that somehow they found out
word spread
and now we're having people like dm me
all day be like hey i'm from brazil hey
i'm from south america
you know my record is 10-0 and now
even more people are getting more people
how do you vet those guys
um through so it's a small every
industry has a small circle right so
everybody knows everybody and
some gyms can't accommodate housing a
fighter you know um so we've been
fortunate enough to be able to have the
resources
to to train fighters to house them to
feed them uh to some degree
and then to train them full time so that
they don't have to worry about getting
another job
they can have full focus on becoming a
world champion
so for people that don't know the
prestige and the history behind your
guys's
gym what's that about um it's led by a
team
he's our head coach um he's been
training since the beginning since like
1996. you know he was
the head coach for tito ortiz um enrico
rodriguez with the ufc champions
and then even quentin jackson and
quentin jackson uh when he was prevalent
in pride
um he's trained not just mma guys but
muay thai guys romeo danza
multiple wbc champions and he became a
coach because was he once a fighter
yeah he was a muay thai fighter he
trained under crew rex who recently just
passed away
and he was a legend of the sport he is a
legend of the sport
and he set a really good example because
fighting is full-time
but he was able to fight full-time in
wutai
and get his law degree at loyola law
school at the same time
which is like unheard of usually when
you go to law school you can't do
anything else yeah um but he was able to
juggle both so he was a pro fighter
and a lawyer yeah so he fought in the
courts and fought in the ring
boom so if he didn't get into being a
lawyer he probably could have been even
better at fighting
yeah so he he he made a decision after
he got out of law schools like i could
be a lawyer
or i can be a fight coach um for
for at the time was kind of like an
unsure thing because in 1997 like the
ufc was just starting out
so um you know you didn't really know
where it was going to go it's kind of
like
this is human [ __ ] fighting at that time
it's not established yet it wasn't
established it wasn't a real sport
some states weren't going to allow it
right yeah it was banned in some states
and so um he was doing his thing and and
it was
he had his team um for a while it was a
lot of old-school guys like rob
mccullough
like all these guys i'm a robber yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
the beach yeah huntington beach tank
abbott
like all these old school guys yeah he
trained all the old school guys
um and then you know now he's got carlos
barza under his belt which is the first
ufc strawweight champion um alex perez
he just fought for the title
uh carlos is the one on youtube where
you see her punch me in the face and i
bleed all over the place
it was [ __ ] it was quite [ __ ] pretty
cool i had like a few droplets like it
was like
so she's like this tiny little girl we
just did we thought it'd be a funny
video for like a power lifter to fight
uh a ufc fighter except it's a chick and
she's what did she weigh like maybe like
110 120 yeah yeah yeah she doesn't even
cut that much weight for fun she comes
in and when she
she shot in when she picked me up i was
like like probably 200. she picked me up
like it was nothing like i i thought i
had to like
like take it maybe slow cause like you
know she's a she's a girl and that's
what my understanding she came she just
picked me up i'm like what the [ __ ] she
slammed me on the ground
i was like bleeding all over the place
like this is crazy oh yeah she's
she's a scary one she's tough too she's
down she is so down
like she does not back down ever yeah
she's awesome yeah so you produce so
your gym produced a lot of
pro fighters and then so it's got that
prestige because early ufc days
and all under your head coach uh mr
oyama
and so if he was a striker like a
kickboxer right and he never really
learned jiu jitsu
like how or did he uh he he knows jiu
jitsu but um what he did was uh he
brought in a jiu jitsu expert
so he was like if i don't know it uh and
i can't answer it i'm not going to give
you the answer but i'm going to find
somebody who does
so he partnered up with jeeva santana at
the time and jeff santana is really big
in the jiu jitsu community
very well respected um very highly
ranked um considering one of the best
coaches out there
and so they worked together for shoot
like almost 10 years
um until jiva you know every fighter's
dream is to open up their own gym
which is the thing anybody's dream is to
want to do their own thing if they're
doing one thing long enough you know and
so uh he finally had the opportunity to
open his own gym and he did it you know
so
really really happy for him and then we
ended up partnering with tent planet
which is a very popular
um organization for jiu-jitsu so we
brought in 10th planet experts
to come in and um and handle our
jiu-jitsu side
and so we have two coaches we've got our
colonel yama and then we've got our
tenth planet coaches that help with the
grappling
does the uh eddie himself come to
he uh so the cool thing is and so with
jiu jitsu you need like an affiliation
you need to be part of like a like a
crew or a gang you know um
so we were the 10th planet and so if you
become a tenth planet gym
uh eddie bravo does a seminar at your
gym so he came down
not yet about flat earth this has
nothing to do jiu jitsu today
it's all about flat earth um so he
hasn't done one yet but we i mean kobe
is kind of messing with everything and
whatnot but uh he's scheduled to do one
over at a template at irvine so
oh cool so yeah he'll come in kind of do
like a cool event and then hit that
going
damn that's pretty cool but it's it's
it's it's cool it's been an awesome gym
and uh i've been grateful to be able to
fall into such a
unique place um for the past
almost 10 years does it have a pool uh
it has a pool of sweat
on the back they're really cool guys i
went to train with them it's super fun
and there's just people of all levels
like
you have your like mid-afternoon
moms coming in for kickboxing you have
your kids after school and then you have
your
like morning serious pros and it's just
such a great mix
with a good vibe yeah we we have this uh
so it's like carpet carpet there's matte
area like you need mats to train in
and right in the beginning of the mat
area there's all these little holes from
the stilettos
from all the girls walking in normal
clothes and it's usually the new people
because oh please don't step on the mats
they're like why i was like
because that happens and it pokes it
through pokes it through so like next
time you guys come look at the mats
there's a bunch of little holes in there
because
high heels from after work yeah coming
in just people coming in and still
levels are just
popping holes in the mat i'm just like
there's no point in replacing it's just
gonna get holy again
do you guys have the little five pound
weights yeah we got three pound weights
one pound weights okay cool
you know funny enough one pound weights
can be really difficult i can like have
a one pound weight over your head and
you'll be like
oh my gosh she doesn't make things
torturous oh [ __ ]
you